I found myself like enjoying a dance a
bit of a dance lately
[Applause]
Brad Pitt tells the world about his
unexpected New Passion dance dance has
become a part of my future or my present
just in life you know I try to find the
find the music in the day the actor
opens up to W magazine revealing he's
found a sweet spot for the art of dance
and when it comes to busting a move he's
even got a go-to song Oh I have a guilty
pleasure what's the the the the the
Spanish version of uh John cicada's
thing from the 90s
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
hell no I'm not gonna sing this is why I
became an actor and Brad well he's a guy
who talks the talk and walks the walk or
should we say dance is the dance
yeah we saw Brad
um tearing it up on the red carpet with
his bullet train castmates at the film's
Paris Premiere in July but we know who
the real dancer in the family is Brad's
16 year old daughter Shiloh
[Music]
we all fell in love with the video of
Shiloh dancing
yeah yeah bro I know
I know that girl is bad yeah brings a
tear to the eye come on yeah very
beautiful I don't know where she got it
from because come on
Mr two left feet here I just saw a
little Shuffle now I just saw a little
Shuffle okay more of a bounce two left
feet are not we think it's sweet the
father-daughter Duo shares the same
motivation to move you ever think like
or do you ever secretly say I don't want
your eyes to be creatives but when you
see oh I love man I love them to find
their own way find the things they're
interested in find their own voice and
flourish well Shiloh is certainly
flourishing on the Dance Floor she's one
of six kids Brad shares with his ex-wife
Angelina Jolie and while Shiloh is
getting her groove on her big sis Sahara
is cracking the books I'm so excited I
feel like my world expands
I learned so much from them and yeah I
love this stage yeah in August Angie was
there to drop her and Brad's eldest
daughter off at Spelman College in
Atlanta and how about this they're all
the son Maddox even helped move his
sister in all right Miss Jolie can you
tell us how does it feel
mom
together it's a big deal how does it
feel to be able to spell my mom
one thing's for sure the Julie pit Crews
got Drive determination and for some a
Devotion to dance
[Music]